التحذيرات المتواتره من مخاطر السجائر
الالكترونيه دفعت العديد من دول العالم
لفرض نوع من الحظ عليها سواء على الحيازه
والاستخدام او البيع والاستيراد او الجمع
بينهما الهند اول بلد في العالم يمنعها
تماما مع غرامات كبيره او عقوبه السجن
لمده تصل الى عام واحد
لتحدثها عده دول تحضر السجائر الالكترونيه
بالكامل منها الارجنتين والبرازيل ونيبال
والفاتيكان وغيرها ويؤدي امتلاك سيجاره
الكترونيه في سنغافوره الى غرامه قدرها
1500 دولار فلا يسمح بادخالها الى البلاد
اما تايلاند لديها بعض القوانين الاكثر
صرامه فتصدير واستيراد سيجاره الالكترونيه
تعرض صاحبها للسجن بين من خمس الى عشر
سنوات او غرامات قدرها اكثر من 800 يورو
الحكومه الفرنسيه تدرس حاليا حضر السجائر
الكترونيه التي تستخدم لمره واحده والتي
تحظى بشعبيه كبيره خصوصا لدى المراهقين
خاصه وان التدخين يحسد ارواح
خمسه طرق سنويا في فرنسا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات